Steven Seagal was one of the biggest action stars
of the 90s — so where's he been lately? From his
weird bromance with a foreign dictator
to his brief foray as a spy novelist,
here's what the Above the Law star has been up to.
Starting in the late '80s, Steven
Seagal took a side job as a police consultant in
Jefferson Parish, Louisiana. Sheriff Harry Lee,
a big Seagal fan, asked the action star to train
his force in martial arts and marksmanship. Seagal
loved the job, and did it for so long that Lee
eventually enlisted him as a reserve deputy.
In 2009, Seagal's side gig became the basis
for a reality show on A&E called Steven Seagal:
Lawman. It was similar to Cops in that
a film crew tagged along while police
officers investigated local crimes
as they happened. The big difference,
obviously, was that the star
of Under Siege was there.
"But no matter how great our deputies are
there's always going to be areas that are
problematic. And we're trying to get those areas."
Sadly, Seagal reportedly resigned from the
force in 2010 after he became the subject
of an internal affairs investigation.
According to the Phoenix New Times,
the investigation sought to uncover the truth
about "allegations of sex trafficking and sexual
assault." Those allegations were corroborated by
two other female ex-employees who alleged similar
treatment by the actor. However, their suit
against Seagal was dropped later in the year.
You may be thinking that
Steven Seagal is very well suited for a
role in a scripted cop series. After all,
TV shows about the police are always pretty
popular, and Seagal spent years beating up
bad guys in movies. Well, you'd be
right because it actually happened.
In 2011, Seagal took his crime-fighting,
butt-kicking act to TV with the action series True
Justice. In addition to creating True Justice,
Seagal played Elijah Kane on the series,
the head of an elite undercover Seattle
task force. The show first aired in Spain
on a cable channel called Nitro before
showing up on the American movie network
Reelz. True Justice ran for two seasons.
In October 2017, Inside Edition
correspondent Lisa Guerrero told The Hollywood
Reporter about her 1996 audition for Seagal's Fire
Down Below. According to Guerrero, Seagal summoned
her to his home for a "private rehearsal" after
the audition. Guerrero declined, and the lead role
she said she was promised went to another actor.
"If you're an actress in Hollywood,
you've been Harvey Weinsteined. In my case,
I was Harvey Weinsteined by Steven Seagal."
Television personality Jenny
McCarthy also spoke out,
saying Seagal demanded she take off her
dress during an audition for Under Siege
2. According to Entertainment Weekly,
Seagal denied McCarthy's allegations.
In January 2018, Rachel Grant, a former
"Bond girl" who appeared in the 007 movie
Die Another Day, went public with her own
story about Seagal's alleged abuse. Grant
told the BBC that during her audition
for Seagal's 2003 film Out for a Kill,
he pushed her onto a bed and pulled down his
pants. Again, Seagal denied any wrongdoing.
Additionally, in January 2018, two women
filed police reports in Los Angeles that
alleged Seagal had sexually assaulted
them. One of the women was Regina Simons,
who appeared as an extra in Seagal's 1994
action film On Deadly Ground. In her report,
Simons offered a detailed account of
Seagal sexually assaulting her when she
was 18. When reached for comment, the LAPD cited
confidentiality laws. However, the department did
reveal that they were investigating yet another
claim against Seagal, according to The Wrap.
After the multiple allegations surfaced,
it quickly became apparent that Seagal
would have to do more than just have his
publicist deny the allegations. So the
actor went on the offensive. While
appearing on Alex Jones' InfoWars,
Seagal told the host he was the victim of
a vast, well-funded conspiracy. The actor
also added that "40 percent" of the sexual
assault allegations coming out of the #MeToo
movement were made up. Seagal also vowed
revenge on the people he said were lying.
Steven Seagal is reportedly good
friends with fellow martial arts movie
star Jackie Chan. So while Rush Hour
3 was entering production in 2007,
Chan was rumored to have suggested
that Seagal play the film's villain.
However, he didn't end up in the role,
and the script was ultimately rewritten to
accommodate Japanese actor Hiroyuki Sanada.
Seagal missed another opportunity for a huge
comeback when he passed on a role in Sylvester
Stallone's 2010 hit, The Expendables. The film
showed that there was still a big audience for
'80s-style action movies, as well as '80s-style
action heroes. The cast of The Expendables series
included Stallone himself, Chuck Norris,
and Jean-Claude Van Damme.
Missing from that list, however, was
Steven Seagal. Seagal ultimately declined
Stallone's offer because he hated one of the
movie's producers, Avi Lerner. The Under Siege
star and Lerner had previously worked on
several direct-to-video features together.
Steven Seagal lives a very full life outside
of making movies. He also spends a lot of time
traveling around the world visiting his
friends who live abroad. As it happens,
two of his best friends are Buddhist
spiritual leader the Dalai Lama,
and Russian president Vladimir Putin. In addition
to his international friends, Seagal gained
citizenship in Serbia in January 2016 when he
offered to set up a martial arts studio there.
Seagal's bromance with Putin has earned
the star some enemies. When he told the
Russian state-run newspaper Rossiskaya
Gazeta that he considers Putin "one of
the great living world leaders," and that he
thinks of the Russian leader like a brother.
"He is one of the greatest world leaders and
one the greatest presidents in the world."
Furthermore, after Putin personally granted Seagal
a Russian passport in 2016, thus formally making
him a citizen of the country, the actor
was banned from entering Ukraine. Writing
in a letter that was published on the news
site Apostrophe, Ukrainian officials said:
"[Steven Seagal has] committed socially
dangerous actions [that] contradict the
interests of maintaining Ukraine's security."
Two Steven Seagal films — The Foreigner and
Contract to Kill — earned the not-so-prestigious
score of 0 percent on Rotten Tomatoes. That
means that every critic who saw both films
didn't like them. Regarding The Foreigner, Scott
Weinberg of eFilmCritic said in his review:
"[This movie is] so bad that it
makes Seagal's other films look
like the combined efforts of
Frank Capra and Billy Wilder."
As for Contract to Kill, a
critic for The A.V. Club wrote:
"[Steven Seagal] gives the kind of
performance traditionally associated
with stars who died during filming. And
yet, Seagal is in almost every scene."
"Who. Is. The target?"
So what do the critics think about the rest of
Seagal's recent, direct-to-video filmography?
Well, those movies haven't even been seen
by enough people to be rated yet. In fact,
as of May 2023, a whopping 53 of his
movies since 2001 are listed as "No
Score Yet" on Rotten Tomatoes. Despite the
action star's incredibly long filmography,
you can count on one hand the number
of "Certified Fresh" movies he has.
"I'm just a lowly, lowly cook."
If you believe there's a secret globalist agenda
that threatens to destroy the United States,
what's the best way of getting your message out?
Well, since this is exactly what Steven Seagal
believes, his answer was to write an action-spy
novel titled, The Way of the Shadow Wolves:
The Deep State and the Hijacking of America.
Co-credited to Seagal and writer Tom Morrissey,
the novel is billed as "a book of fiction based
on reality." The plot follows an Arizona tribal
officer who untangles a high-reaching conspiracy
among drug smugglers, the mainstream
media, and the United States government.
As with many of Seagal's films, the reviews
weren't exactly kind. In December 2017,
The A.V. Club highlighted a series of Amazon
writeups and social media posts that gleefully
mocked the book and its authors. Furthermore,
A.V. Club critic Nathan Rabin "hate-read" the
entire book in order to offer an in-depth
rundown of the story. On the other hand,
the right-wing classic rocker Ted Nugent
posted on Facebook that he loved Seagal's book.
In September 2017, Seagal appeared on Good Morning
Britain to weigh in on the national anthem. At
the time, a large number of professional athletes
were protesting racial injustice and inequality in
America by opting not to stand during the anthem.
"We have a lot of people that aren't treated
equally, aren't given equal opportunities."
It's a complicated issue that's inspired
no shortage of debate, but from Seagal's
point of view, it's all very simple. While
insisting that he believed in free speech,
Seagal made it clear that he was
deeply offended by the idea that
anyone would refuse to stand during
the anthem. He told host Piers Morgan:
"I don't agree they should hold the United
States of America and the world hostage by
picking a venue where people are tuning in
to watch a football game and imposing their
political views. I think it's outrageous,
I think it's a joke. It's disgusting."
According to multiple actors,
Steven Seagal is an incredibly difficult person
to work with. John Leguizamo, who co-starred
with Seagal in 1996's Executive Decision,
discovered this the hard way. While filming the
action-thriller, Seagal got angry with his co-star
and allegedly shoved Leguizamo against a wall.
Seagal also made life hard for the Saturday
Night Live cast. While hosting the show in 1991,
he was "very critical of the cast and writing
staff," according to Live from New York:
The Complete, Uncensored History of
Saturday Night Live as Told by Its Stars,
Writers, and Guests. Tim Meadows is
even quoted as saying in the book:
"[Steven Seagal] didn't realize
that you can't tell somebody they're
stupid on Wednesday and expect them to
continue writing for you on Saturday."
David Spade, meanwhile, said that in his six
years on Saturday Night Live, Seagal was the
absolute worst host, which probably had a lot to
do with his taste in comedy. For instance, former
cast-member Julia Sweeney noted in Live from New
York that Seagal had an idea for a sketch in which
he played a therapist who attempts to sleep with
a rape survivor. As it turned out, Seagal was so
impossible to work with that he was banned
from ever hosting Saturday Night Live again.
Stephen Tobolowsky also learned firsthand about
Seagal's difficulty on set. In The Glimmer Man,
Tobolowsky played a serial killer. So,
naturally, Seagal was supposed to blow
the bad guy away. But then, as Tobolowsky told
The A.V. Club, Seagal decided it was "bad for
his karma" to keep killing people on-screen.
So he wanted Tobolowsky's character to survive.
"This is god's house, don't make me do this."
Thinking on his feet, Tobolowsky quickly
explained that his character was trapped
in his own private hell. So by killing
the villain, Seagal would be allowing the
bad guy to reincarnate as a more peaceful being.
Seagal agreed, and the scene went on as scripted.
In addition to acting, Steven Seagal has
done quite a bit of fight choreography. According
to IMDb, most of the films he's choreographed are
his own. In the early '80s, however, Seagal
worked on the James Bond film Never Say Never
Again. Apparently, he was brought in to teach Sean
Connery about martial arts. Connery, however, was
already well-versed in karate. While preparing for
1967's You Only Live Twice, he was even awarded
an honorary third-degree black belt. But for his
seventh outing as Bond, Connery needed to learn a
little aikido, so Seagal was hired to teach him
how to throw opponents and manipulate joints.
At first, the lessons seemed
to be going well. In fact,
they were going too well. As Connery admitted
to Jay Leno on The Tonight Show in 1996,
"And then I got a little cocky because
I thought I knew what I was doing [...]"
But then things took a turn
for the worse. From there,
an irritated Seagal allegedly
grabbed Connery's arm and broke
the actor's wrist. While he was undoubtedly
in pain, Connery kept on training. In fact,
he didn't realize that Seagal had actually
snapped his wrist until the late '90s.
Of course, Seagal can take a bit of pain as
well. While working on his breakout film,
1988's Above the Law, actor Henry
Silva broke Seagal's nose with an
overzealous punch. Knowing the show must
go on, Seagal stayed up late that night,
icing his battered nose so he could
keep on shooting the next day.
Steven Seagal has battled all
sorts of bad guys on the silver screen,
from terrorists to the yakuza. But he's
also faced some scary villains in real
life, namely the mafia. In the '90s,
Seagal teamed up with producer Julius R. Nasso.
Together, the duo made a string of hits. However,
their relationship soured in 2000,
and the two eventually had a falling
out. But things took a dark turn when
the Gambino crime family got involved.
One day, Seagal was ordered into a car and
escorted to a Brooklyn restaurant. It was
there that he met an alleged Gambino captain named
Anthony "Sonny" Ciccone. According to CBS News,
Ciccone ordered Seagal to start working
with Nasso again. He also demanded that
Seagal fork over $150,000 for every film
he made. Evidently, Seagal was so shaken,
he gave the gangsters $700,000. The martial
artist had every reason to be afraid. Because
as CBS News reported, as Seagal left the
meeting, someone supposedly told him:
"If you would have said the wrong
thing, they would have killed you."
The scandal came to light in 2003, when
the government indicted alleged crime
boss Peter Gotti and 16 others for
a whole host of crimes. In addition
to Seagal's testimony, the government
had recordings of several individuals,
including Ciccone and Nasso. In the
recordings, the two men discussed how
they would intimidate Seagal. They even laughed
about how they had scared the movie star.
Nasso defended himself by saying Seagal had backed
out of several movie deals, and owed him $500,000.
Regardless, the producer was sentenced to one year
in federal prison. But once a crooked mob guy,
always a crooked mob guy. Nasso wanted his
cash, and sued Seagal for $60 million. After
the producer got out of jail, he settled with
Seagal for an undisclosed amount of money.
While never a critical darling, Steven
Seagal used to pull in some impressive box office
numbers. But throughout the 2010s, the majority of
Seagal's films went straight to DVD or streaming.
Furthermore, Seagal isn't making as many movies as
he used to. In fact, as of April 2023, Seagal's
last film, Beyond the Law, was released in 2019.
So what happened to Steven Seagal's career?
Well, he blames his decline on the FBI.
In 2002, Los Angeles Times reporter Anita Busch
was investigating Seagal about Julius Nasso and
the producer's association with the mafia. But
one morning, she found a dead fish, a rose,
and a sign that read "Stop!" on her windshield.
There was also a brand-new bullet hole in her
car. Afraid, Busch informed the FBI. As a result,
the feds began investigating Seagal. At first,
the FBI thought the actor had hired a detective
named Anthony Pellicano to intimidate Busch.
Pellicano was a private eye who would later be
convicted of illegally spying on celebrities.
The FBI also suspected Seagal of hiring a thug
to scare Vanity Fair writer Ned Zeman with a gun.
"I know you, don't I?"
But after digging deeper, the FBI concluded
there was no evidence against Seagal. Instead,
they focused on Pellicano. And then, Seagal just
fell by the wayside. The FBI never charged him,
but they didn't exonerate him either.
According to the Los Angeles Times story,
the actor believes all the notoriety from the
Pellicano case majorly harmed his career — and
he may have a point. As one Hollywood
publicist told the Los Angeles Times:
"Steven Seagal was no Harrison Ford
when this [scandal] happened. But
these accusations certainly hastened his decline."
So it only makes sense that Seagal wants
an apology from the FBI for possibly
destroying his career. As for Pellicano,
he was convicted on wiretapping charges
in 2008 and sent to prison. Having served his
time, Pellicano was released in March of 2019.
Steven Seagal's hands aren't just for breaking
people's bodies — they're also for making sweet,
sweet music. Yes, the star of Hard to Kill is also
a long-time musician who loves the blues. Whether
the blues loves him back is another question
entirely. Seagal has been playing guitar since
age 12 and heads the Steven Seagal Blues Band. It
wasn't until 2005, however, that Seagal released
his first album, Songs From the Crystal Cave.
The album features straightforward blues,
though the songs aren't nearly as grimy
and soulful as something you might here
form B.B. King or Buddy Guy. In fact,
SputnikMusic called the album "the 'Plan
9 From Outer Space' of records." There are
various reasons for the album's harsh
criticism, such as Seagal's mumbling,
half-asleep singing style. The actor's less
than impressive guitar-playing also didn't
wow the critics. Additionally, the album featured
some downright bizarre lyrics, such as this gem:
"You're like a ghost / The more you eat,
the more you're hungry / A hungrier ghost."
He's got Russian citizenship, a willingness
to offer his many opinions on a wide variety
of subjects, and a measure of celebrity.
So, it was probably only a matter of time
before the Russian government offered Steven
Seagal a job. That time came in August 2018,
when Seagal was made a "special envoy for
humanitarian ties" with the United States.
That's a fancy-sounding gig, but as
the Russian Foreign Ministry noted
when announcing Seagal's appointment,
it's an unpaid position. It's also a
position that's a little difficult to
understand, at least in terms of Seagal
actually being able to get anything done. As
the Ministry's description of the role notes:
"[The envoy's job is to] facilitate relations
between Russia and the United States in the
humanitarian field, including cooperation in
culture, arts, public and youth exchanges."
One of 2022's most original and
critically adored films was The Menu,
a black comedy served with a zest of social
commentary and a dash of horror. Among other
big names who appeared in the film,
such as Ralph Fiennes, Anya Taylor-Joy,
and Nicholas Hoult, the movie featured John
Leguizamo as a movie star named George Diaz.
In the film, the Diaz character is
no longer relevant as a movie star,
instead fading into obscurity as he
becomes an ever-increasing target of
ridicule. For inspiration in playing this washed
up has-been, Leguizamo chose his former co-star,
Steven Seagal. During an interview with
Entertainment Weekly, Leguizamo certainly
didn't mince words when revealing where his The
Menu character came from. He told the outlet:
"I kind of based [my performance]
on Steven Seagal. I had a bad run-in
with him. [...] He's kind of a horrible human."
"What are you blind? We're closed, okay?"
"You kind of talk too much."
Since Seagal's position with the
Russian government is mostly honorary,
it doesn't necessarily signify anything
about the actor's politics. However,
it's harder to say the same about Seagal's
decision to hold his 70th birthday party in
Moscow in April of 2022. After all, in attendance
at the bash were two pro-Putin journalists,
both of whom had already been sanctioned by the
European Union due to Russia's controversial
invasion of Ukraine. Seeing as Putin's invasion
of Ukraine occurred only a few months prior,
in February of 2022, Seagal raised
eyebrows when he told his guests:
"I love all of you and we stand together,
through thick and through thin."
Putin is not Seagal's only
controversial friend in politics,
however. The actor has publicly voiced
support for former Philippine President
Rodrigo Duterte, a leader whose
strict stance on crime earned him the nickname
"The Punisher." Seagal has also demonstrated
his support for Venezuelan President Nicolas
Maduro, a leader whose
divisive tactics have led many news outlets to
either question his status as a democratic
leader or outright pronounce him a dictator.
"You're hanging around with the wrong people."
One of the great gifts of being
a famous actor is the ability to diversify
your income with celebrity endorsements,
and Steven Seagal hasn't missed the opportunity
to do just that. In 2018, the actor lent an
endorsement to Bitcoiin2Gen, a cryptocurrency
aiming to rival Bitcoin. He also received a
tidy sum for his support. However, Seagal
failed to disclose the payments he received,
which violated U.S. federal law and led to charges
from the Securities and Exchange Commission.
According to the SEC, Bitcoiin2Gen promised Seagal
$250,000 in cash and $750,000 worth of B2G
tokens as payment for his promotions. The
actor ultimately received around $157,000. But
since he never reported his earnings, Seagal got
in trouble. On its website, the SEC explained
the reasoning behind the charges, writing:
"These investors were entitled to know
about payments Seagal received or was
promised to endorse this investment so they
could decide whether he may be biased."
Common sense also supports the SEC's reasoning,
as celebrities obviously advertise
products they don't necessarily support,
solely for the paycheck. To Seagal's credit,
upon learning of his offense, he cooperated
with the SEC investigation, ultimately paying
around $314,000 in disgorgement and penalties.
In addition to John Leguizamo and
the cast of Saturday Night Live, you can also
add Charlize Theron to the list of celebrities
who dislike Steven Seagal. During her June
22, 2020 appearance on The Howard Stern Show,
Theron made it abundantly clear that she
despises Seagal with a passion. When Stern
asked Theron how she prepares herself mentally
for her roles in action films, the actress said
that she often watches YouTube videos of
martial artists and their fights, adding,
"You always come across that odd Seagal
video of him 'fighting' in Japan,
but he really isn't ... He's overweight and
can barely fight. Look it up, it's ridiculous."
When Stern remarked on how comfortable Theron
seemed in publicly mocking another well-known
industry professional, the actress told the host:
"[I have] no problem talking s--- about
[Seagal] because he's not very nice to women."
Though she didn't elaborate, Theron
was likely alluding to the multiple
accusations of sexual assault and misconduct
leveled against Seagal over the years.
It's no secret that Steven Seagal
is known for his international adventures, both on
and off the screen. As a friend of Vladimir Putin,
Seagal continues to meet with the Russian
President fairly regularly. But apparently
becoming a Russian citizen wasn't enough
for the American actor. According to CNN,
Putin honored Seagal in early 2023 with
an "Order of Friendship." As the news
network noted, Putin cited the actor's
"great contribution to the development
of international cultural and humanitarian
cooperation" as his reasoning for the honor.
The award itself is a relatively recent
invention, having first been instituted by
former President Boris Yeltsin in 1994.
Seagal's award comes off the heels of
his 2022 visit to a destroyed Ukrainian prison
during the conflict between Russia and Ukraine.
Appearing on the government-owned network
Zvezda, Seagal surveyed the damages with
the intent of educating those who haven't seen
the destruction first-hand. It should be noted,
however, that the actor did all of
this from a Kremlin-based perspective.
But what more can be said about Seagal's strange
ties to Putin and the Russian government? The
actor has made some very interesting choices
in recent years — including his infamous
birthday party in Moscow. He also consistently
finds himself honored by Putin and the Russian
government, so one can only wonder what position
or award Steven Seagal will be given next.